a stuffy nose sneezing watery eyes hello
seasonal allergies but not to worry
intermountain healthcare who is
sponsoring this segment they are here to
help let's welcome the show jeff tackett
who is a pediatric primary care nurse
practitioner certified for intermountain
healthcare welcome to the show and let's
start with what are seasonal allergies
sure so really seasonal allergies are
when our body
gets introduced to allergens so like
pollen from trees and grass so that gets
introduced the body then decides oh we
think this is far and we're going to
attack it so it releases a couple of
chemicals one histamine which most
people know about the other one is
leukotrienes so when those chemicals get
produced that's when your body makes the
symptoms so you'll typically have
sneezing runny nose congestion those are
just a couple of the common ones but
there's some other ones as well okay
with everything's going on in the world
today how do we know the difference
between colvid and seasonal allergies
sure that's a great question right the
biggest thing with seasonal allergies
you should never have a fever so
anything over a hundred point four you
can't attribute that to seasonal
allergies that's going to be the main
thing is absolutely the biggest main
thing so yesterday i think life happens
for you there's a reason you and i are
talking today because actually i had my
allergies were kicking in yesterday i
had a sneezing attack as a kid i didn't
have any of these issues do you grow
into your allergies yes so basically
that's kind of the primary premise of
that so what happens is you're exposed
to these
allergens over time your body just gets
the point where it's like hey we really
think this is foreign we're going to
attack so that's why you may not have
any kind of issues for several years and
then all of a sudden it gets boom
yeah absolutely how okay how do we treat
it so the best way two things one the
best thing non-pharmacologic wise make
sure that if you know your specific
allergen you want to avoid that time of
year right so for instance olive trees
are
a big time in the fall so that's really
when you're going to have a problem
there so that's number one number two
when you're outside come inside take
your clothes off go get in the shower
quick rinse off get the pollen off of
your skin the other thing make sure if
you have carpets at home make sure
you're vacuumed very frequently okay and
also that applies to couches just like
our chairs here they're upholstered so
we're going to make sure that we clean
those as well is there a test that you
can do you mentioned know what you're
allergic to is there a test that i can
do to find out that i'm allergic to my
dog
the horses so there's a couple of
different tests one that we use uh
primarily in children is a very simple
blood test so we draw blood it's gonna
test for about 20 to 25 different common
allergens just like we talked about with
dogs and cats
tree pollen oak
olive it also is going to test for
cockroach and
rat and mouse droppings because those
are some common allergies too most
people don't think about those okay
that's how common is that and so if you
if your child test positive for those
kind of allergies just make sure you
have an exterminator come out and make
sure there's no mice absolutely yes yeah
and the big thing too like take your
garbage out every day make sure you take
the garbage outside that's another big
huge thing for for kids who are
cockroach and mouse dropping allergies
well this is a busy time of year if you
uh japanese allergy season is high gear
thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it it's very informative
today thank you thank you for having me
and i want to get that test out i need
to find out what's causing my sneezing
attack yesterday thank you to
intermountain healthcare for sponsoring
this segment for more information you
can visit their website which is right
there on your screen now in today's
entertainment